here arthur are you going to play for
england
no why not
happy and dreaming of a football career
this is how arthur's uncle wants us to
remember this little boy
bye
it is how his community will remember
him as they gather today in their
hundreds for a vigil
tributes to a six-year-old tortured
starved and poisoned
whose murder has now prompted the
government to launch a national
investigation
the top priority has got to be looking
for those risks reading the signs which
may only be subtle
and then with the benefit of hindsight
be more obvious but at the time i do
think though we've got to make sure
if you like a more precautionary
approach which looks at the the risk to
those particularly vulnerable young
children and see what more we can do to
read those signs earlier and better
the government says the review will be
deep and independent its aim to ensure
this doesn't happen to another child
while the review is welcomed in the
community the pain is still raw
the focus here is to remember a little
boy
who never should have died
i feel like it's the same every time
there's a review we learn lessons but
nothing actually changes we can't have
it happening again can we
you know
it's a terrible thing that's happened
it's
it's a nightmare so hope it never
happens against another little boy
i just think it's affecting everybody
yeah it's terrible can't believe it's
happened
it should never ever happen again
it has happened again
this is yet another review
those behind previous investigations
say funding is an issue
we know that what we've got to do is
find out what's been happening within
families have the time to do that and
share the information across the
different professionals different
workers working with that family to
build that picture up sometimes to think
the unthinkable that is all what we know
that we have to be doing
that is being squeezed out and
structural change will just be a big
distraction
as tributes at football grounds
continued today the attorney general is
reviewing whether the jail terms handed
down to arthur's father and stepmom are
too low
although it's too late for him now
there is no shortage of love here
outside a house
that didn't have any
damn white is sky news
in solihull